depuis des semaines il ne cesse de tirer
la sonnette d'alarme artisan boulanger
ou encore restaurateur ils sont
confrontés à la hauteur de la fin de
leur facture d'énergie alors comment
s'organise-t-il pour faire face sans
impacter leur clients quelle mesure
attentive du gouvernement élément de
réponse avec Gabriel Gontier et Ludivine
canard décroissant à 1 euro dépend au
chocolat à 1,35 mais pour encore combien
de temps dans cette boulangerie de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les factures
mensuelles ont été multipliées par plus
de 3,5 passant de 2000 euros à 7500
euros le compteur de 7 gérante dépassant
une certaine puissance elle n'est pas
éligible au bouclier tarifaire elle doit
donc faire face il n'est pas éligible
puisqu'on était des contrats qui sont au
dessus de la principale
donc c'est en train de bouger ça va se
mettre en place et là on attend un petit
peu de voir qu'est-ce qui va se passer
réellement ce qui consomme le plus les
trois fours de cette boulangerie or
impossible pour cette artisane de son
passé
même constat à quelques pas chez ce
restaurateur qui emploie 14 salariés
donc on a eu X3 déjà sur le gaz depuis
le début de la guerre en Ukraine et en
Russie et là on est en train d'essayer
de négocier parce qu'on a des prix
d'électricité qui vont aller x 6 x 7 x 8
donc
nous on a aujourd'hui des coûts
d'électricité qui aussi entre 2005 et
3000 euros par mois entre le gaz
électricité et là demain s'il y a pas de
maîtrise on sera sur du 15 20.000 euros
quoi par mois un coût considérable pour
cet établissement de 800 mètres carrés
qui doit continuer de tourner malgré
tout on mange sur notre trésorerie
on essaye d'économiser comme tout le
monde c'est à dire que on a supprimé des
fours supprimer des chambres froides
décalés on a mis moins de lumière plus
de LED on avance tous les jours on se
lève et on essaye de trouver des
solutions mais on est très inquiets le
gouvernement a annoncé PLA le prix du
mégawater à 280 euros un soulagement
même s'il faudrait aller encore plus
loin pour ce restaurateur avec un
bouclier tarifaire pour tous un report
du paiement des impôts et des
cotisations à également été annoncé les
professionnels pourront aussi résilier
sans frais leur contrat de fournitures
d'énergie en cas de hausse des prix
prohibitives alors la situation est
compliquée on vient de l'entendre pour
les boulangers les restaurateurs en ce
moment avec nous pour en parler Olivier
Girard bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde vous
êtes le président de la Fédération des
boulangers et des pâtissiers des
Yvelines alors est-ce que vous avez reçu
des des alertes de boulanger oui
énormément alors la situation est
complexe parce que en écoutant ce
reportage je veux dire tout est dit et
rien n'est posé beaucoup d'aides sont
alors évidemment je souhaite une très
bonne année évidemment à tous nos
artisans boulanger pâtissiers et tous
nos yvelinois qui nous écoutent
la problématique est énorme
aujourd'hui on nous propose des aides
mais comme toute celles-ci il y a
toujours des petits Astérix là on nous
parle d'une baisse de 380 à 280 ça
s'adresse seulement à ceux qui sont à
moins de 10 en effectif donc évidemment
ça représente que 70 ça représente 70 %
des boulangeries pâtissiers concernés
après ceux qui sont au dessus qui sont
appelés 10 évidemment ça va être très
compliqué parce que là on s'envole sur
du donc 280 on va jusqu'à 500 jusqu'à
1000 il y a un premier Bouclier qui a
été proposé justement qui peut pour
permettre voilà de retirer 20% sur
l'augmentation et évidemment il prend
pas en charge nos collègues qui
travaillent encore au bois ou au fioul
voilà donc ne peuvent pas en bénéficier
et sur le deuxième donc le guichet
automatique qui met en 20% dessus donc
ça fait pas 40 mais ça fait 20% des de
de donc on est sur du 136% et bien là
c'est pareil il faut avoir 3 % supérieur
à son consommation éner sur son bilan
par rapport à l'année dernière en
sachant que le N-1 ne correspond pas du
tout à la réalité parce que l'année
dernière nous étions encore en plein
covid donc automatiquement il y a 85 %
de boulanger qui se retrouvent avec
entre 257 et 2,97 donc évidemment ils ne
peuvent pas prétendre encore à cette à
cette aide donc oui excusez-moi
Duke des finances publiques et il nous
avait parlé des boulangeries sur les
290 boulangeries 390 boulangeries
seulement 5 avaient demandé des aides
alors comment est-ce que vous expliquez
cela alors c'est tout simple c'est
toujours la même chose on nous parle de
numérisation sans arrêt numériser les
documents etc donc nos boulangers
passent de plus en plus de temps
derrière leur ordinateur au lieu d'avoir
la tête de dans le guidon dans leur
voilà dans leur fourni il faut savoir
que là pour l'instant ils étaient pas
tellement concernés parce que
ils ont on a vécu le covid et sur le
covid la baisse de l'énergie n'a jamais
été aussi basse on s'est retrouvé donc
entre 5 et 10 euros du kilo donc
évidemment
je veux dire à ce moment-là des beaucoup
de contrats ont été faits et ces
contrastes terminés donc fin décembre
2022 ou sur 2023 parce que actuellement
il y a encore des boulangers qui ne sont
pas concernés par cette hausse vis-à-vis
de du fait que je veux dire il n'y a pas
eu cette augmentation vu qu'ils sont
toujours dans leur contrat mais quand
ils se sont quand ils se sont quand ils
s'alarent il est trop tard nous en 2000
fin 2021 on commence à recevoir de la
part de confédération nationale de la
boulangerie-pâtisserie en nous disant
attention en fin 2022 ça va être le
chaos et en effet on rentre dans un
chaos alors 2022 là on nous parle de
boulangerie qui ferme alors évidemment
il y a des boulangers qui ferment parce
que le la crise énergétique bah c'est
c'est la guillotine et
on avait des boulangers pâtisserie qui
avaient cette problématique sur fin
2019-2020 et 2021 qui veut dire aurait
dû se retrouver en RJ un RJ excusez-moi
je lui dis redressement judiciaire
excusez-moi donc un redressement
judiciaire c'est de l'argent parce que
il y a un mandataire etc ça coûte de
l'argent donc quand il y a eu je le
quoique il en coûte et le PGE ils se
sont dit mais on va elles se sont dites
ces boulangeries je vais me redresser
voilà je vais m'aider de cette PGE le
problème c'était de de comment je veux
dire de propager le mal un peu plus loin
qui s'est terminé sur 2022 donc dedans
on a des boulangeries bah évidemment
parce que en plus il y a eu cette hausse
des énergies excusez-moi cette hausse
des matières d'oeuvre des matières
premières donc voilà donc évidemment
farine beurre je vais pas vous vous
l'avez déjà évoqué plusieurs fois dans
cette émission donc donc ça plus la
crise énergétique alors là c'est voilà
c'est ça y est c'est le c'est même plus
l'épée d'avocation comme je vous ai dit
c'est la guillotine la situation
difficile qui est devenue chaotique on
l'a compris qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait de
plus justement pour vous accompagner
pour nous ce qu'on demande parce que
voilà et il y a deux choses qu'il faut
comprendre là-dessus c'est que une
boulangerie pâtisserie voilà et je je
l'espère en Yvelines et je veux dire on
en a beaucoup qui sont sur du tout
maison ça représente 35 à 50% de masse
salariale vous imaginez vous prenez une
baguette vous la coupez en deux voilà ça
c'est déjà pour ma masse salariale donc
c'est pour vous dire que une entreprise
fonctionne grâce à ses collaborateurs
ces collaborateurs qui eux commencent
excusez-moi du terme mais vraiment à
flipper parce que si on s'annonce sur
février mars et en avril sur une comment
je veux dire une eau significative et
qu'il ne va pas être endigué comme vous
le dites je vais dire il va y avoir du
chômage ces gens là ont des prêts et on
ne famille etc donc on risque là on
rentre complètement dans une crise
sociétale donc pour revenir sur le fait
ce qu'on demande donc même si notre
Président je veux dire œuvre tous les
jours parce que souvent il est molesté
je veux dire sur les réseaux etc je peux
vous affirmer que lui bouge énormément
avec je veux dire avec le gouvernement
et notre président de la République le
seul problème c'est que évidemment ils
sont tenus également par la Cour
européenne parce qu'on ne peut pas aider
parce que vous voyez on rentre dans une
dans une aide exactement donc oui c'est
très bien comme le reste l'expliquer
monsieur Morton sur le fait que de
mettre de défendre les les particuliers
on met le tarif bleu plus 15%, la
plupart sont des boulangers pâtissiers
sont à 86% en tarif jaune donc c'est
pour ça qu'on est sur cette complication
alors évidemment par exemple un tarif
bleu c'est en dessous de 36 un four
c'est déjà entre 36 et 45 donc on est
obligé de demander un compteur spécial
qui coûte encore plus d'argent et donc
le fait c'est que ce compteur nous on
demande tout simplement et j'espère que
on sera suivi c'est que le tarif jaune
soit comme le tarif bleu donc plus 15 %
même 20% mais on sortira d'une situation
qui risque comme vous dites mais qui va
se contaminer et je veux dire on a 30000
boulangers en francs boulanger
artisanaux en France et qui crée
derrière aussi une concurrence déloyale
pourquoi parce que déjà déjà moi je
voilà ce matin j'avais un boulanger qui
me disait mais Olivier comment peux-tu
comprendre que dans une supérette déjà
on voit des baguettes à 60 centimes
qu'il paye déjà leur boulanger etc comme
si et leur farine qu'elle soit française
et qu'elle ne viennent pas de Pologne
etc des baguettes toutes faites avec 4
fois plus d'ingrédients que dans une
baguette de tradition française mais là
pour revenir sur sur le fait de comment
je veux dire de cette de cette
concurrence déloyale elle est toute
simple je veux dire ce que les terminaux
de cuisson les trois plus simples
certaines supérettes sont sur le tarif
bleu vont avoir que
15%. voilà donc automatiquement nous on
pourra pas et on sait toujours dit nous
artisans boulangers pâtissier quand vous
vous êtes très jeune mais quand il y
avait le franc c'était la baguette le
journal le café et le timbre à un franc
ça c'est fait pareil quand on est passé
à l'euro maintenant lequel des trois des
quatre est resté 1 euro la baguette
pourquoi parce que on veut que la
baguette soit encore accessible à tous
nos compatriotes parce que comme souvent
le risque d'augmenter cette baguette
prochainement moi ce que je pense que il
va falloir que tous les acteurs jouent
le jeu parce que même aussi nos
fournisseurs parce que là les prix du
blé ont baissé alors je sais le problème
c'est que nos menhirs rencontrent aussi
des difficultés du fait que avec leur
flotte de transport ils vont être
obligés de passer à tous l'électrique
les camions électriques quand ils
arrivent tous les toutes les toutes les
semaines donc hier ils sont ils sont
obligés d'être réparés parce que en ce
moment il y a pas de fiabilité sur les
sur les moteurs électriques pour les
gros camions pour les camions qui
livrent intra-muros de donc de
l'Île-de-France donc Paris et qui va
s'étendre
et puis le fait c'est que il faut à tout
prix que cette comment je veux dire ce
tarif bleu se propage sur le sur le
tarif jaune et bien merci beaucoup
Olivier gérardons
avec nous je le rappelle vous m'avez dit
sur la baguette oui alors la baguette
elle va augmenter alors cette baguette
ce que je souhaiterais c'est que elle
reste à 1 euro il est beaucoup plus
facile par exemple sur les pins spéciaux
de mettre un peu plus d'euros parce que
les gens peuvent comprendre les pains
spéciaux on a environ sur 8 à 20 euros
je veux dire je je c'est voilà c'est un
constat donc là on ne sait plus facile
de mettre par exemple 50 centimes sur
les pins spéciaux que de mettre remettre
10 centimes sur la baguette blanche
parce que il y a un truc qui est tout
simple qu'il faut pas oublier là
Monsieur monsieur Morteau le rappeler
c'est très bien on a une population qui
dans le besoin bon nous on veut que les
que ces gens là que cette population
mange du pain frais et du bon pain
qu'est-ce qui va se passer c'est que une
baguette à 1 euro 50 vous en prenez deux
pour la famille ça fait trois euros les
gens qui travaillent qui touchent entre
900 et 1300 euros vous leur mettez 100
euros je veux dire de plus 100 euros en
pain c'est un budget ça faut pas
l'oublier c'est pour ça que c'est un
problème sociétal c'est que là
aujourd'hui on allait savoir faire
artisanaux qui sont reconnus par
l'UNESCO et demain qui est-ce qui va
faire cette baguette vu qu'il y aura
plus de boulangers artisans donc la
baguette ne devrait pas trop augmenté
mais les autres baguettes j'aimerais que
mes confrères et j'aimerais aussi que
nous fournisseurs agissent là-dessus
mais c'est là je parle en tant que voilà
en tant que Président j'aimerais que
cette baguette vous savez comme certains
prix voilà on touche pas trop au
croissant on pain au chocolat on touche
pas trop je veux dire à certains
sandwichs etc pour que mais
malheureusement ils vont être obligés à
un moment ou un autre parce que c'est
pas logique là on double dit c'est fois
4 vous imaginez vous arrivez au magasin
je vous dis tiens Mathilde la baguette 4
euros vous allez me dire mais oui je
fais comme voilà comme eux x 4 merci
va-t-il merci beaucoup